.
TYRANNY IS THE NAME OF THAT
SYSTEM.
IT'S SPREADING BECAUSE NO ONE IS
SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
CANDACE OWENS HAS SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT IT, ALWAYS HAS.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT THEY'RE
ADDRESSING THESE BIG,
THEORETICAL MACROISSUES AND
CHANGE THE AMERICAN JUSTICE CODE
TO BE RACE-SPECIFIC, SOMETHING
IT'S NEVER BEEN, THEY'RE
IGNORING THE COLLAPSE OF DAILY
LIFE FOR THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
YOU SEE THIS EVERYWHERE.
WHAT IS IT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT DOES SEEM TO BE A VERY
STRANGE COLLISION AND SEEING HER
PUT THIS FORTH IS JUST ACTUALLY
-- I'M INCREDULOUS.
SELFISHLY, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IT GO INTO PLACE FOR MAYBE ONE
DAY BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
BRILLIANT FOR BLACK
CONSERVATIVES BECAUSE EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT WOULD FALL BY
THEIR SWORD.
OF COURSE, THEY WOULD BE LOCKED
UP FEDERALLY, TRUST ME, IF THIS
GOT PUT INTO PLACE.
THIS YIELDS MORE QUESTIONS FOR
ME I'M LOOKING AT THIS THINKING
WHAT ARE THEY POSSIBLY THINKING?
HOW WOULD THIS WORK?
WHAT ABOUT BLACK-ON-BLACK
CRITICISM?
WOULD THEY LOCK ME UP FOR SAYING
SOMETHING LIKE SHEILA JACKSON IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A LOW I.Q. HATEFUL
INDIVIDUAL IN IF I DID SAY THAT,
WOULD I GO TO PRISON?
HOW WOULD THIS RUN PARALLEL TO
THE DECRIMINALIZATION EFFORTS?
THEY DON'T WANT ANY BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE IN PRISON.
THEY WANT THEM ALL TO BE ON THE
STREETS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THEY'RE SAYING THEY'D LOCK US
UP.
WOULD THIS EXTEND TO AN OVERSEAS
POLICY?
WOULD I BE LOCKED UP IF HE SAID
ANYTHING BAD ABOUT THE LATE
OSAMA BIN LADEN?
THIS WASN'T WELL THOUGHT THROUGH
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T NEED TO BE.
WE KNOW THEIR EVERY EFFORT IS
AIMED AT CENSORING SPEECH,
RIGHT?
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO BE OMNIPOTENT, THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO CONTROL WORDS.
IF THEY COULD CONTROL WORDS,
THEY COULD CONTROL THOUGHTS.
ULTIMATELY WHAT THEY'RE AFTER IS
BRAIN WASH.
BY THE WAY, THEY'VE BEEN REALLY
GOOD AT BRAIN WASH, SPEAKING OF
WHAT YOU JUST SPOKE ABOUT.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GRADUATING -- I JUST TALKED
ABOUT THIS TODAY.
GRADUATING HARVARD WHO ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT MEN COULD BE WOMEN
AND WOMEN COULD BE MEN.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS CHANGE OUR
MINDS.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
AFTER AND ULTIMATELY WHAT THEY
WANT IS FULL POWER AND CONTROL
OVER EVERY SINGLE PERSON AND
THEIR HOUSEHOLDS.
>> Tucker: THEY'LL USE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO IT AND THE
POLICE AND THE FBI AND THE
COURTS -- I WONDER IF WE'VE
LAUGHED TOO MUCH AT THE
ABSURDITY OF ALL OF THIS AND NOT
INTERNALIZED HOW DEADLY SERIOUS
THEY ARE ABOUT USING POWER TO
CRUSH THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
>> OH, I HAVE BEEN LAUGHING BUT
AT THE SAME TIME POINTING PEOPLE
TO THE VERY REAL TRUTH AND SAID
WHAT THEY TRULY WANT IS A
TOTALITARIAN SOCIETY.
THEY'RE FOLLOWING THE PLAYBOOK.
EVERYTHING THEY'RE AFTER,
THEY'RE ATTACKING RELIGION,
ATTACKING THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THEY CONTINUALLY WANT TO REMOVE
GUNS FROM YOUR HOUSEHOLDS.
WHAT DOES THAT SPELL OUT TO YOU?
WHERE HAVE WE SEEN THIS BEFORE?
FOR EVERY COMMUNIST SOCIETY THAT
EXISTS, HAS EXISTED AND EXISTS
TODAY.
THEY WANT TO REMOVE INDIVIDUAL
POWER.
IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE THEY'RE
BREAKING DOWN PEOPLE'S
MENTALITY.
WE'RE BECOMING A FUNDAMENTALLY
WEAK COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT CRY AT THE
DROP OF A HAT BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN MISGENDERED.
THEY KNOW THESE PEOPLE CAN'T
TAKE THEM ON IN THE FUTURE.
THEY CAN'T STAND UP TO
GOVERNMENT WHEN THEY CAN'T STAND
UP TO THEMSELVES, LOOK
THEMSELVES IN THE MIRROR AND SAY
ACTUALLY, I CAN'T JUST WAKE UP
AND SAY I'M A MAN OR I'M A
WOMAN.
IT'S SO MACVILLIAN.
YOU CAN LAUGH TO STAY SANE BUT
RECOGNIZE SOMETHING VERY REAL IS
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IT'S DANGEROUS SINISTER.
>> Tucker: IT COULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED FIVE YEARS AGO.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE.
CAND